hello everyone and welcome to the
Women's World Chess Championship it's
around four of the match you when June
the reigning world women's world chess
champion versus at the winner of the
candidates tournament alexander gory
athena and it's it's a really exciting
game and up until a game for the three
previous games were drawn there were
chances for both sides but in the end
all of them ended in a draw and before
we check out the game we do have some
nice photos to check out off of this
game so here this there's jus in June
before before the game starts
let's just enjoy that for a second there
we have gory Akina she's always looking
like like she is very angry or like
she's coming to get you but I think
she's just a very focused well at all
times of the match and also here is a
nice photo of the two of them if it's
the starting position basically a few
moves into the opening so that being
said let's check out the game and also
the match is being played in Shanghai
China only the first six games then the
other six games will be played in Russia
and Vladivostok and it's a 12-game match
the prize fund is half a million euros
so it's it's half of what was the prize
fund in the cross and versus corwin
imagine 2018 in London but I've I've I
think I'm pretty sure I've seen an
interview with Peter president Arkady at
work which where he said that they have
plans for the next year it was the last
year's interview so I think they're
talking about this year that they are
really trying to equalize men's and
women's prizes and prize funds and of
course winner get 60% loser gets 40 40 %
unless there's a tie if if there's a tie
after 12 games and they have to go into
in two tiebreaks then it's 55 percent to
45 percent yeah deal so that being said
let's check out the game game for soju
engine opens with d f-- d for now we
have d5 c4 and c6 the Slav defense we
have Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and the
now Knight to c3 now I'm good actually
no capture CD captures in c4 and now a
for controlling b5
and now be interpreter five is the most
popular move here however gorya channel
goes for east 6 we have III and now c5
going for the central right away
hi this has all been played before
Bishop captures and see 4 characters
captures and Knight to c6 putting
pressure on the center continuing
development with castles by Jew and
Bishop to e7 and here
quinta e 2 also one of the possible
ideas but now a Jew and Jim goes for d5
so the knight is under attack you have
to react to this and the King is still
in the center of the board so it doesn't
make sense to try something we have a
capture some d5 we have a trader in the
center Knight captures Knight captures
Bishop characters and now black takes
this opportunity to Castle as if you
don't Castle now things could get ugly
so castles and white continues
developing pieces you could you could
mess up black's pawn structure here with
better captures and c6 but then you give
black the bishop pair yeah and well yeah
that's just not not worth it
so Bishop to e3 continuing development
and now with Bishop f5 the vessel
Interpol had this position in 2017 in
Gibraltar chess festival against counter
and he defeated him with Bishop to f6
but here in Goryeo Cena goes for Bishop
to a5 instead developing an undeveloped
piece so Queen to b3 putting pressure on
the f7 pawn may be nice the knight can
come to e5 or g5 sometimes in the future
and also putting immediate pressure to
the b7 point so here there is a one game
where Knights the AFI was played but
here we have night to b4 and this is a
new move so it is as a move 14 that we
have a completely new game and this is
basically where our game starts as both
of them surely prepared very very nicely
for each other you know openings wise so
here if you go after the pawn it's not
really not really the greatest decision
because if you capture just rook b8 and
the bishop has no squares you could make
a square for the bishop with the knight
to d4 freeing the DF 3 square for the
bishop while also attacking
undefended bishop here problem is after
this bishop moves and you go back then
just nice to see to opens up an attack
on the queen and also the rook is under
attack so you will lose the exchange
here
so after this night before we have rook
F to D one already Jew Jew in June has a
threat of just Bishop characters picking
up the Queen here so Queen to a5 now
just getting the Queen into the game
developing connecting rooks also there's
the threat of just Knight captures
Bishop on d5 sense now the bishop is
attacked twice and here a very
interesting move with Knight e5 so what
do you do here well you don't really you
don't really have have an option here so
we have in Knight captures Bishop we
have rook captures Bishop on d5 and now
getting the Queen out of the way Queen
to a six and now White has to be
prepared for Bishop to e6 Bishop to e6
would just win material so it's a it's a
very big threat you have to react to it
somehow and here ooh engine goes for the
very nice Knight to d7 which opens up a
once again an attack towards this
undefended Bishop and also offers a
trade here Bishop for night so go Tina
doesn't doesn't enjoy that she just goes
Bishop to e6 now this will win the
exchange but also your rook on f8 is
under attack so it's just a trade we
have Knight captures and f8 pink actress
and now Queen to b5 forcing the trade to
happen on b5 as if you don't react the
rook will just move and if you capture
then the rook will recapture and well
white will be up the exchange so you
have to capture on d5 but rope captures
on d5 Queen captures on d5 and now rook
to d8 getting the rook into the game
without wasting time and if you if you
think about it it's actually black who's
up in development but but the rook on a
one is actually very useful now as it
defends the a four point so Queen back
to e4 and now h6
not allowing this point to remain a
target while not worrying about Queen to
h7 if Queen to h7 then you can just
f6 and any checks will be met with King
to f7 and the king will be very safe on
on f7 it's a light square white no
longer has a light square Bishop so it
would it would work out very well so
white also creates some breathing room
for the king with g3 and now b6 as both
of these points are target so the Queen
can't really move so b6 pretty much
takes care of everything we've looked a
see one now with ideas of bringing the
rook to the seventh rank with rook to c7
so now f6 it's it's a very interesting
idea because well one one would think
that you will not play f6 unless
provoked
for example if Queen comes stage 7 then
okay f6 but garage kinda decides that
it's better to do it preemptively so f6
King to g2 improving the position of the
king and now rook the c8 just offering a
rope trade we have rook capture screen
capture so now it's two queens two
bishops and five points each and Queen
to d5 so for the moment the difference
is that white has a very active Queen
and this is why white is better for the
moment so of course black wants to
counter that we really know goes Queen
to d8 preparing to trade Queens so the
so the King has to defend the D file
with h4 and now Queen to d7 just
defending now we have Queen to g8 check
Bishop to f8 blocking and now Queen back
to c4 so just exploring the the
territory with h5 s or h5 by black
preventing further expansion and the
Queen's a king side by white and now
kink to h2 not allowing the the King to
be exposed on any polite square diagonal
such as this one so King will be safer
there and the f2 point will always be
protected as it's on a dark square so
the bishop protects it we have Bishop to
e7 and now b3 we have King back to f8
and now Queen to c2 again seeing what
what's what's happening here maybe maybe
you can somehow go after this point
is on a light square so Bishop to d6 by
black and now Queen to efore just again
and I centralized you move with the
Queen and here garage Gina is not
satisfied with the just repeating moves
after the 57 so she offers a trade with
Bishop to c5 now the downside to this
idea is that well you ruin your pawn
structure you get two isolated points on
the Queen side and you also allow white
to really push this pawn all the way to
a six so that's that's the downside so
of course Joe and Jim captures with
Bishop captures be captures and now a5
continuing to push the pawn we have
Queen to e7 now offering a trade but
first Queen to a eight with check now
you cannot block with the Queen sends
the a seven point four so King to f7 and
now a six so that's a that's already a
very nice pawn there we have G sets by
black and now Queen to d5 with check if
Queen b7 you're just gonna ignore white
of course you're just gonna continue
playing here we're putting on f6 and
it's just gonna be a queen stalemate
so after g6 we have Queen to defy with
check King g7 and now Queen back to B
sub not with the threat of capturing the
Queen but just King f8 we have King to
g2 now white wants to get the King into
the game as well we have King to e8 and
now again Queen back to eight with check
King f7 and now Queen to defy with check
repeating the position a few times and
now King to g7 this is move 43 so I
forgot to mention it is now not allowed
in this match to offer a draw before
move 40 so here they are allowed to
offer draw so King g7 and now kink the
f3 improving the position of the of the
White King as much as possible if you
could get the White King somewhere here
and then trade Queens of course you will
be completely winning but that's easier
said than done of course the black Queen
will not allow that
so kink the f8 garage pin a repeats
Queen to b7 again repeating and now King
Teti a and now here is the the question
of the game now that your king of course
we already had this position when the
King was on h2 we had it when the king
was on g2 now we have it when the
on f3 so does this change anything is is
the King and pawn and game much better
winning equal for white or not so this
is what you have to decide so feel free
to pause the video and try to figure out
what what to do here and how to continue
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who decided to trade
Queens and go to into a King and pawn
endgame I will will go back to that and
for those of you who decided on
something else
congratulations as that is exactly what
Jew decided to do so she played the
Queen back to d5 we have King to f8 and
the now comes King to f4 so trying to
increase the activity of the white king
even further before even attempting a
queen trade so black of course doesn't
allow this Queen to c7 check and now
kink the e3 King to e4 is also possible
but maybe you don't want to allow black
any any trickery you will have to
calculate every move every check black
has to make soaking back the e3 maybe
you can now transfer the King gas
somewhere here maybe pick up the c5 pawn
but now Queen the c8 and now Queen the
b7 again if you continue with with the
king then it could be could be dangerous
if the if the black queen infiltrates
also the point is under attack so you
have to react to that
so quinta b7 defending and now Queen
back to DA not allowing the white king
to the cross anywhere sorry
those are weird arrows to towards the
c-4 square so King back to f3 we have
Queen to e7 again defending and now we
again reach this exact same position ok
the king is an f8 instead of an e 8 but
doesn't really matter since after after
a capture happens it's the same
recapture so here gieux decides that now
it's time to recap to capture the Queen
so here we have Queen captures King
characters and it's the same the exact
same position so congratulations to
those of you who decided to trade Queens
when I asked that the first time and now
g4 the point is you wanna weaken the
King sight as much as possible so you
have access to this pawn so if captures
captures then you will
access to this pawn that's how you want
to continue with King 2d six characters
on H five characters on H five and now
King to e4 so preventing the black the
black king from sorry about that
grabbing more squares in the center and
White has a more active King now White
King is already on the fourth rank and
well the black King still hasn't reached
the center of the board so what do you
play here well there are two ways you
can do this you can go left you can go
right if you go kink the e6 you want to
prevent the White King from going after
this pawn it's not a problem
king of four and black is unable to gain
opposition that's one one thing you
always need to watch out for King d5 now
you're going to go King to f5 and now
King d4 you're gonna play not this
because then captures and you will
capture this and then black sea point
will also be very fast
you're gonna go quick ink that e-cigs
instead so now if you force the King to
c3 which is what black will do now you
don't capture you go King d5 so if
captures then you have captures so black
will defend it a king to before and now
you're gonna play King to c6 and now
using such you know you know sneak
thieving so to say you will reach the b7
square pick this up and now you're a sex
pawn is extremely strong so if King gave
five then you go King to b7 you capture
it you move and then you promote the
pawn to Queen so this is what happens if
black goes King to e6
so of course be really not try to kink
the c6 but now f4 again you're waiting
for black to decide if he's gonna go
back with King to d6 or he's gonna go
King to b5 gotcha cannot goes kink the
b5 goes after the pawn here but now King
to d5 if you go King to f5 it's not not
gonna be not gonna be great because King
before again picking up this point and
then this point marches forward so after
King beef i we have kink to d5 so if
captures you can always capture here and
now you have to decide what to do
a lot of ideas are
possible of course if you capture on a
six then you get keen captures on c5
King a5 and now you want this position
but you want you want it to be black
smooth so f5 you force black to make a
move now his King has to go away
he cannot approach the pawn the heater
has to move or play a six doesn't really
matter but now you have King c4 again
you do not allow any squares to the
black King and only after the black king
moves and then you go King d5 and now
you go after this pawn king b5 we're
gonna go King g6 King before King
captures on f6 King characters and b3
King g6 and now of course a5 you can
pretty much see who's faster a3 queen
pawn here and now anything wins for
white if you just put the Queen here
block this square
even if black promotes it up to a queen
you're just gonna pick it up and the
Queen the other pawn after we eliminate
the h5 point so that's what happens if
you capture the ACE exponent so
periodically not went F 5 instead but
now it's again a different different
story Queen King to d6 King to b6 again
gaining opposition you don't want to
trade here so King b6 and now King to d7
even better because now black is unable
to gain opposition so now you you either
capture and you allow King here and then
the king will capture on c5 so cucaracha
gonna go is king the a5 instead but now
again not king to c6
because if King to c6 then you can
capture and after characters King a5 we
get the position that we already
discussed but it's white to move white
once this position where it's black to
move so after King a5 not going King
ceases but King c7 instead and now it
works
so King captures an a6 King to c6 white
gains the opposition King gave 5 and now
you capture now it's the exact same
position only it's black to move so you
cannot use any of these squares you can
only go up the board so King a6 now be
for taking away the a5 Square from the
black King King b7 and now came to d5
and here it was in this position unmoved
63 that Alexandre chorin
resigned game and the first victory of
the match goes to Joe and June taking a
victory in Game four of the match so I
just demonstrate how easy it is to win
this it's not all that easy it's it's
actually done to want one tempo because
once this King grabs the beef or pawned
the beef or pawn well is done before and
after whiting eliminates this guy the F
pawn Queens on s8 which delivers check
the before so the problem for garage
Gina is white Queens width
check so if you if you run it out king
b6 King e5 you go here you capture
captures now the King moves anywhere
a5 now you start f5 a for now f6 a3 f7 a
- and it seems like you're both queening
but not really because Queen f8 comes
with check black has to move and again
Queen g7 just keeping an eye on the
queening square and again you will not
care even if black promotes the Queen
you can just capture it capture this
pawn Queen D H bond and then checkmate
the black ink so really impressive stuff
and as reference 100 anakin filled or
said points really are the soul of the
game as you can see here so jus in june
demonstrated that very nicely so that's
Game four of the Women's World Chess
Championship 2020 I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank a Herald hotter
mark on meeting in Adam lever Michael
Buckley and Bradley Peterson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content now so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day